Un'area in cui il quantum computing potrebbe migliorare il machine learning
è legata alle funzioni kernel o
alle matrici kernel. Vediamo cosa sono
e perché ne abbiamo bisogno. Per farlo, ricorderemo
tre cose: perché i prodotti scalari compaiono nel machine learning,
perché i problemi di machine learning coinvolgono dimensioni elevate
e cosa sono le funzioni kernel.
Ricorda che il prodotto scalare, o prodotto interno, di
vettori reali n-dimensionali a
e b è dato dal prodotto della magnitudine di a
e della magnitudine di b per il coseno di theta, l'angolo
tra di loro. Questo equivale a moltiplicare
ogni componente di a per la componente corrispondente di
b e sommarle. Nota che se i vettori sono
quasi ortogonali, come quando a
ha componenti nulle dove b ne ha di grandi,
il prodotto scalare è piccolo. Questo equivale a
theta che si avvicina a pi greco fratto due.
Allo stesso modo, se a ha componenti negative mentre b
ha componenti positive,
ovvero i vettori puntano in
direzioni quasi opposte
e theta è vicino a pi greco,
il risultato del prodotto scalare potrebbe essere
negativo. Infine, se a ha componenti grandi dove anche b
ha componenti grandi dello stesso segno,
così i vettori sono quasi paralleli e theta è vicino a zero,
il prodotto scalare sarà grande
e positivo. È quindi ragionevole aspettarsi che i prodotti scalari
siano una misura utile di similarità
tra i punti dati. Non tutti i dati n-dimensionali
possono essere facilmente separati con un taglio in n meno
uno dimensioni, ovvero con una retta,
un piano o un iperpiano. Quando i dati non sono ben separati
in n dimensioni, possiamo incorporare i punti dati
in dimensioni superiori, diciamo m dimensioni, dove m
è maggiore di n. Questo si chiama feature mapping
e si denota spesso come x che va a phi(x), dove
phi(x) è una mappatura dai numeri reali n-dimensionali ai
numeri reali m-dimensionali.
È più facile da visualizzare quando si
piega un insieme di dati unidimensionali in
due dimensioni, o si prendono dati bidimensionali
e li si incorpora in tre dimensioni.
Ma in pratica spesso incorporiamo i dati in spazi con migliaia
o persino milioni di dimensioni.
Un prodotto scalare di vettori tridimensionali rispetto a un prodotto
scalare di vettori bidimensionali è una differenza trascurabile.
Ma un prodotto scalare di vettori con un milione di dimensioni
diventa completamente intrattabile
da applicare a un dataset di grandi dimensioni.
Così le persone hanno trovato un trucco ingegnoso:
e se usassimo una proiezione
in dimensioni superiori con una forma molto specifica
tale che i prodotti scalari dei vettori in
dimensioni superiori siano una funzione semplice dei
vettori a dimensioni inferiori? Cioè, troviamo una mappatura
dai nostri dati x a uno spazio superiore phi(x)
tale che il prodotto interno nello
spazio delle feature sia dato da una
funzione semplice nei dati a dimensioni inferiori.
Questa funzione k si chiama funzione kernel.
Idealmente vorremmo che questa funzione kernel
fosse una funzione del prodotto interno
a dimensioni inferiori stesso. Questo ci darebbe il
meglio dei due mondi: uno spazio delle feature ad altissima dimensione
ma con un prodotto interno economico e facile da calcolare.
A prima vista potrebbe non essere
ovvio che questo sia possibile. Guardiamo
un semplice esempio in dimensioni molto basse.
Considera questo specifico feature mapping: mappa un
vettore tridimensionale in uno
spazio a nove dimensioni. Si scopre
che il prodotto interno nello spazio delle feature a nove dimensioni
è semplicemente dato dal prodotto interno nello spazio
tridimensionale originale al quadrato. Quindi il prodotto interno
dello spazio mappato usando le funzioni phi
richiederebbe il calcolo di ciascuna delle
nove coordinate per il
primo vettore e nove per il
secondo, poi il prodotto interno stesso, che sono
altri nove prodotti e una somma:
in totale ventotto operazioni.
La funzione kernel richiede tre prodotti
e due somme, corrispondenti a sole quattro operazioni.
Questo valeva per la mappatura di un punto dati tridimensionale in
uno spazio delle feature a nove dimensioni.
È facile vedere quanto questo potrebbe essere molto vantaggioso
per spazi molto grandi.
La funzione kernel è tipicamente una funzione continua
che puoi applicare a qualsiasi vettore nel tuo dataset.
Ma usiamo le funzioni kernel prendendo
coppie di punti dati dal nostro insieme
come argomenti. Applicare una funzione kernel a
ogni coppia di punti dati nell'insieme
produce una matrice simmetrica chiamata matrice
kernel. Il tipo di funzione kernel da usare dipende dal
problema. Quindi, per ricapitolare:
descrivere la similarità dei vettori nei nostri dataset
richiede spesso prodotti interni. I prodotti interni in
spazi delle feature ad altissima dimensione diventano costosi.
Quindi usiamo feature mapping corrispondenti
a certe funzioni kernel speciali
che rendono il calcolo più efficiente.
Ma questa restrizione alle funzioni kernel speciali
limita il tipo di mappature nello spazio delle feature che possono
essere eseguite in modo efficiente. Questo
potrebbe impedirci di separare bene i nostri dati.
Se solo ci fosse un altro modo...
Ed è qui che entra in gioco il quantum computing.
Il feature mapping ad altissima dimensione corrispondente
alle funzioni kernel può essere eseguito
su un computer quantistico. Nel quantum kernel estimator,
la matrice kernel k viene calcolata
e da lì un algoritmo classico di machine learning può essere
usato per completare il task. Un punto dati x1
viene caricato e mappato, poi
un altro x2 viene caricato
e mappato. Poiché il prodotto interno di due stati quantistici
è legato alla probabilità di misura,
possiamo stimare il prodotto interno dei due punti
dati mappati effettuando un numero sufficiente di misure del
circuit risultante. In questo modo, il circuit
ci può informare su un prodotto interno
in qualsiasi spazio ad alta dimensione che il circuit riesce a modellare,
senza che noi calcoliamo mai classicamente un prodotto interno o una
funzione kernel. Esistono molti modi di
personalizzare e migliorare questi metodi,
e ci sono sempre nuovi metodi proposti
e testati. Speriamo che questa
panoramica ti sia stata utile per inquadrare
l'applicazione del quantum computing
ai metodi di machine learning,
in particolare quelli che coinvolgono i kernel.